so you want to get good gift ideas so
you can get a good gift perfect gift
actually to a boyfriend because you want
to show him just how much he means to
you right right
mine is pretty hard I know because
there's so many stuff out there and
you're not sure if it's gonna like what
you're gonna give him but don't worry
I'm here to help I'm gonna give you 25
good gift ideas that you can get your
boyfriend so let's not waste any more
time let's get right into the video made
mistakes but mistakes make you stronger
hey I'm Daniel and if this is your first
time here on my channel welcome
subscribe click the notification bell
and then you won't miss any of the next
videos so how do you get the best gift
for your boyfriend well first of all
that's a few things it depends on what
he needs what he likes meaning his
hobbies are we gonna look at both of
those areas so why those two areas
because you need to know that men don't
really like stuff that I cannot use and
that's not a bad thing that's actually a
very good thing for you because think
about it if you get him a gift that he
needs that he uses that he likes all the
time then he's always gonna think of you
because you're the one that got him that
gift so it's a win-win all right so
let's go through this list quickly let's
start first with the things that he
really needs number one
[Music]
every guy needs a good-looking wallet
like this one from Tommy Hilfiger or
this one from Rwanda and hey just so you
know all the other links of all the
gifts for you in a video description
down below so you can go and check it
out
your guy shaves all the time get him
this nice shaving kit from Jaclyn or if
he doesn't like shaving and he has a
nice beard getting this nice grooming
kit from Rapid Theater
[Music]
nice watch like one of these guys that
will fit in with his main clothing style
your boyfriend wants to look good
unattractive for you right but if you
think that he can improve a little bit
on his clothing style don't tell him
just getting something that looks really
good and tell him hey hon you're gonna
look amazing in this all right if you're
not sure what to get I've added some
good options for you video description
where you can check out basic clothing
essentials for men jackets we got shoes
everything is in there check it out
sunglasses every guy likes a good pair
of sunglasses get him a nice pair of
plastic aviators or the Wayfarers
because those type of sunglasses they
fit any type of facial
a good cologne now this is actually not
just a gift for him but for you as well
because you're gonna smell all the time
these guys they are by far some of the
best clones out there on the market
check it out it doesn't have a good
electric shaver yet and if he shaves a
lot get him this guy from Braun it's
really gonna make his life a lot easier
it has a beard and it likes trimming
getting this one a good skincare set now
we live in the age where men are finally
something to take more care of
themselves looking good for you so if he
doesn't have a nice skincare routine yet
getting one of these skincare sets he's
really gonna improve his skin a lot so
he feels better and more confident about
how he looks now let's move away from
the stuff that he needs and we're moving
towards the stuff that he likes he's
hobbies now this is gonna be a little
bit more difficult because men are
different right but there's a few stuff
that we all have in common a cool game
yes there's a little boy in every adult
big guy out there it doesn't matter how
old they are there's a little boy in
each of us right so we love games most
of the guys out there so I'll add a
friend a bit of description so you can
check it out while we're talking about
the games what are you guys you're gonna
thank me for this but if it doesn't have
a Playstation yet get him a Playstation
but you he's gonna beat into heaven well
actually if you're not along in the
relationship don't get him PlayStation
that's that's too too nice a gift let's
move on
get in one of these if it really likes
eating the gym and working out if you
likes fixing stuff get him or upgrade
his toolbox he's really gonna like that
or give him something else he needs like
a nice four creeper so it's easier for
him to work on your car when it needs
fixing so you need to be smart about
these things if you like sport it's a
no-brainer getting tickets to his
favorite sporting
[Music]
if you likes music well everybody likes
music so get him a nice headphone a
wireless headphone I got one on my
birthday and I love it
if he's got an adventurous personality
type and he loves going outside and
doing stuff outdoors then get him a nice
GoPro yeah it's a little bit expensive
but if you've been in a relationship for
a long time it'll be a winner but if you
have the money and you want to do better
than a GoPro you can get him a nice
drunk well actually no that's that's too
expensive leave that until you're
married yes
he likes gadgets and tech he might like
that EcoPlus
if you likes coffee it's a no-brainer
get him good quality coffee
it's a little bit cold already so it's a
good idea getting the Ember temperature
control mark so that his coffee never
gets cold
she likes cooking get him a proper
chef's knife get him up apron as well
they can go with
if it likes golf you gotta get him the
indoor hunting dream I mean actually
most guys would love this in a man cake
even if they cannot play golf the likes
fishing can get him this affordable
fishing scale and this to go with it all
right that was a lot but we were at the
last one and this is the most important
one you gotta listen up all right the
most important gift that you can give
him is you your attitude towards him how
you make him feel about himself and
about you it's very important so when
you give him the gift it's not just a
gift in that moment your personality
towards him your attitude towards him
he's gonna make him like that gift a lot
more poor nah it's just it's a nice gift
but it's a nice gift if you liked the
video give it a thumbs up subscribe and
I'll see you in the next video Cheers
[Music]